Chairman Kim and I just signed a joint
statement in which he reaffirmed his
unwavering commitment to complete
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
they interrupted the Bachelorette for
that anyway this is big news but it's
only a start a first date if you will
verification is key for in the past
North Korea has been about as
trustworthy as sushi from the drugstore
on a Thursday in the summertime but
maybe that past is dead check out this
movie trailer that President Trump
presented to Kim destiny Pictures
presents a story of opportunity a news
story a new beginning one of peace to
men
two leaders one destiny
a story about a special moment in time
when a man is presented with one chance
that may never be repeated
what will he choose to show vision and
leadership or not a new world can begin
today one of friendship respect and good
will be part of that world where the
doors of opportunity are ready to be
open okay that is amazing
can't wait for the movie yes and it's
got to be a first showing a world leader
what the world could be like if you
change your ways as a movie trailer who
does this Donald Trump why why did he
show him this I showed it you because
that's the future I mean that could very
well be the future and the other
alternative is just not a very good
alternative not at all
see it's about two options the golden
off ramp or the cliff to nowhere this is
not politics its persuasion it reframes
the future so the past is the past
this isn't thinking outside the box it's
getting rid of the box really Trump just
did a sales presentation on freedom no
one has done that before well Kim do
what's right I think he's gonna do these
things I may be wrong I mean I may stand
before you in six months and say hey I
was wrong I don't know that I'll ever
admit that but I'll find us I'll find
some kind of an excuse
now that's transparency now this should
feel like good news but if you still
believe the summit was itself a
concession then it won't but without
thinking why have diplomacy we'd be
stuck in one place forever so what
should reassure you our new crew Pompeyo
bolton Trump this isn't Kerry Hillary or
that guy Ben Rhodes entitled lemmings
out for legacy they were all carrot the
new guys mostly stick which makes the
carrot possible the establishment will
laugh but just months ago the same
people who thought Trump was leading us
to war are now mad that he's averting it
screw him as for you you should greet
this news with hope not illusion let's
check back in a year worst case
we're back at square one that's no
concession just a path tried what did
one great philosopher say see what
happens we will see what we will see
we'll see what happens we're gonna see
what happens let me see what happened so
we'll see what happens we'll see what
happens alright okay kill me I'm going
to you first because frankly I feel bad
for you it's over all yes in general has
anybody ever done this before present a
video it's like a timeshare a
condominium video that a sales man will
show you to get you to go on the tour it
what this could be start of something
new where you go to color countries and
go this is what you could have it's
great and by the way I could not back
your decision to come to me here's why
it's a good decision why I actually
watched a 10 and they got up at 1:30 to
do the show at 5:00 so I actually have
not been decided watching a Singapore
time yeah and now we're back in East
Coast time so a couple of things he also
said this on the condo episode he said
you know watching those missiles those
Rockets take off for the hit Japan I'm
thinking about self that's a beautiful
beach it's going over yeah we could put
condos yes and he's like that could be
the convent yes so I'm just saying he is
I know there's a lot of reasons to say
it's not gonna work but all I could say
is keep your powder dry if you are quick
to criticize the president because this
you've got to understand is just step
number one of a brand new series of
stairs
yeah cause nobody knows where this is
heading but I know for sure it's not
done yet and the pressure is really on
them because this is the best chance
they'll ever have to give their people a
future and give theirs give their their
monarchy whatever you call it some type
of security and if they want an example
its Vietnam and China command economies
where we never want to live but they
found a way to put some market
principles in there where we actually
get along with both Vietnam probably
gets along with us better than China and
Russia these days so I am encouraged by
the chance there's plenty of reasons to
poke holes in it though this term which
i think is not great commits to work
towards complete denuclearization is not
complete denuclearizing the entire
peninsula however it's a
step and guess what happens next week
Boulton and Pompeyo pick up where this
summit left off
game on yeah what do you think Dana I
think this is uh I mean I'm skeptical
but I also have a feeling of hope I'm a
little boy yeah I think that that's true
but I I kind of feel the same as I did
yesterday yeah except for I didn't like
I don't know I had too many zenus like
looking at the flags side by side you
know that he's like an equal partner Kim
really did get a lot out of this he's
got all the propaganda that he can use
back home now Rush's has to come to him
to have a meeting the Chinese are gonna
come to him to have a meeting he no
longer has to go there although he might
do that as well the video does remind me
of that idea I had a long time ago that
I asked General Petraeus today when he
was at the CIA which was to create a
video showing suicide bombers like the
underwear bombers right could happen to
them mm-hmm
with like a little mix exactly exactly
risky it could be yes is that the
alternatives what happens when your
crotch lives yes yes exactly that's what
I was trying to movie I believe i zoom
me Terry on today's she's at she was a
former CIA deputy director for Korean
issues and she said overall Net+
yeah okay so I think that's probably
where I was yesterday well as you're
describing I'm hopeful but I'm skeptical
I do think that personnel is policy in a
lot of ways so the fact that Bolton and
Pompeyo are going over there is good I
do wonder though if the people who are
critical of it like many on the left
there's some of the right but people are
critical of it because they're looking
at this and saying it's not strong
enough we're the same ones that praised
President Obama for Iraq yeah so I just
think that consistency and skepticism
about these things is warranted play
this video for I think I'll play this
for Wan this is Donald Trump is gonna be
on Hannity tonight you're familiar with
Sean Hannity all right heard and they're
gonna they're gonna talk about the early
rhetoric that Donald Trump employed
let's roll that tape for the work well I
think without the rhetoric we wouldn't
have been here I really believe that you
know we did sanctions and all of the
things that you would do but I think
without the rhetoric you know other
administer
I don't want to get specific on that but
they had a policy of silence if they
said something very bad and very
threatening and horrible just don't
answer that's not the answer that's not
what you have to do so I think the
rhetoric I hated to do it sometimes I
felt foolish doing it but we had no
choice what do you think one
I think he's celebrating himself he's
rationalizing what he did before but it
said he met him in a mistake excuse me
no he said that maybe he felt bad doing
it yeah a mistake he said it worked it
to the contrary he's but I mean to me
this whole thing I listened to you guys
and I think boy what look at the
defenders of Trump today I mean this is
like a wet firecracker this is like real
is like the end of The Sopranos where
you go what happened to my TV that
anything happened to this show what
happened here that was a great series I
mean but you got to remember the man who
set the bar for this was none other than
our TV star Donald Trump Donald Trump
said no lengthy negotiations like my
predecessors remember yes what he said
he said no concessions that will stall
and simply give this horrible regime
more time to perpetrate their terrors
and he said quite clearly we're gonna
talk about human rights otto warmbier so
today says oh otto warmbier didn't die
in vain oh but you didn't mention you
didn't bring up instead she did strike
it was amazing we brought the
repatriations as well might be accurate
I'll be accurate what do you say well
here's what Kim said we agreed to let
past the past be the past we're moving
on yeah but that's what he said Kimberly
I see so let me finish so here you have
a situation attend you say oh you say Oh
are these lemmings Bo you say you say
Carrie and others are lemmings yeah
diplomatic is otto warmbier one of the
lemmings - did he just go away just go
off the edge that I did not say that
I was so wrong I said I did not call war
pure LSU boron let me just say something
you'll say oh we're going down a path
that's never been tried before I guess
you've never read about Bill Clinton and
the framework agreement in which the
North Koreans took concessions don't
deliver how about the six-party talks I
stopped listening to you when you said I
hear more on Kimberly bring up human
rights Kimberly yeah thank you so mean
honestly what are we in North Korea
right now listen I got an opinion too
and I think that it was incredible to
watch last night so many of us were
riveted by it it is an important moment
in not just American political history
but in international discourse and
diplomacy I really hope and pray that
this is the first step of yes many
meetings between the United States and
North South korea-china be able to work
together nuclear scientists involved to
be able to trust but verify which was
Reagan's policy and really work towards
peace no one benefits you know from war
and so in that sense I think this was
something that was important it's a step
in the right direction can he say that
he trusts 100% the actions of that man
that has run you know a brutal regime of
torture and behaved in a way horrific
Lee to his own people no but perhaps we
have some small part to play in stopping
that from shedding some light on it and
not continuing to remain to have them
isolated to create and commit their
horrors without the rest of the world
knowing about it
I believe the president when he says
that otto warmbier did not die in vain
because that really did cast a very
bright light on what was going on in
North Korea and I think really was
really so pivotal in terms of being able
to get POWs am i you know remains home
be able to negotiate for the other
hostages that were held there that does
matter to those families and those that
have been grieving and looking to bury
their loved ones so I say let's give
this a chance kudos to our president for
being able to make this
which how many people didn't think
exactly how do we get out of this we
said we're gonna stop our new our
exercises with South Korea Oh what do we
get in return we get promises pledges oh
my gosh you know you god you're such a
baby wanna go we got we got completely
new prompt or not I say I'm just telling
you something remember you have people
who say the Iran deal stinks right
terrible the Iran deal the Iranians
didn't have nukes and we had a deal to
stop them from getting news right now
they're quickly getting them how did
that happen North Koreans have nukes
well they have we are after 70 years of
doing what given that we are saying that
this is about non clear frag nukes using
your old traditional diploma from Trump
I do not believe you're acting like the
Donald Trump rewarded bad behavior what
did Bill Clinton do by moneymaker this
guy the only thing is meet with them and
start by starting a there's a reason why
they didn't tell me because because they
didn't have nuclear weapons they weren't
a that's us the multistage Rockets can
now hit the lower 48 states and there
was a legitimate military threat that
brought them to the table right guys
we're gonna do another block on this
believe it or not if we're still here